14 miliardi di anni tutto il tempo
dell'universo o quasi
davanti ai nostri occhi questo è il
privilegio degli astronomi vedere il
passato letteralmente possiamo vederlo
pensate un paleontologo per capire come
era fatto un dinosauro possono basarsi
sui fossili che trova o uno storico
ricostruisce fatti lontani affidandosi
ai racconti e ai resti dell'epoca noi
astronomi no niente di tutto questo
noi vediamo l'evoluzione dell'universo
con i nostri occhi e dell universo
stesso che ce lo consente l'universo che
ogni giorno disegna il suo passato
attraverso la luce che emana
vediamo come è più semplice di quel che
sembra sappiamo tutti che la luce
viaggia velocissima 300.000 chilometri
al secondo
un miliardo di chilometri orari si dice
alla velocità della luce per indicare
qualcosa di istantaneo ma la luce non si
propaga istantaneamente sulla terra non
ce ne rendiamo conto perché le distanze
sono piccole per capirci un segnale
luminoso è in grado di compiere il giro
della terra ben 7 volte in un solo
secondo
come potremmo renderci conto che non è
istantanea ma nello spazio le distanze
sono enormi
la luce ad esempio copre la distanza
terra sole in 8 minuti per arrivare
dalla stella più vicina oltre il sole
impiega quattro anni e per arrivare
dalla galassia più vicina alla galassia
di andromeda ci mette due milioni e
mezzo di anni
questo vuol dire che quando ammiriamo un
tramonto
in realtà il sole già sceso sotto
l'orizzonte e lo ha fatto otto minuti
prima
vuol dire che se in questo istante
qualcuno ci stesse guardando dalla
galassia di andromeda non vedrebbe noi
vedrebbe l'uomo habilis perché questa
era la specie che popolava la terra due
milioni e mezzo di anni fa
e così anche noi se osserviamo oggi
andromeda la vediamo come era due
milioni e mezzo di anni fa e non abbiamo
modo di sapere come oggi perché la luce
che lei sta emettendo non c'è ancora
raggiunti
vediamo insomma la sorgente come era
nell'istante in cui la sua luce è
partita e ha iniziato il suo viaggio
verso di noi anni milioni o anche
miliardi di anni fa siamo un po come il
destinatario di una missiva di altri
tempi che si ritrovava a leggere di
avvenimenti accaduti magari mesi prima e
di quelli doveva accontentarsi però
capite per noi astronomi questo non è un
disagio è una fortuna enorme più
osserviamo distante da noi più ci
affacciamo su epoche remote è un po come
avere tante istantanee di quello che è
stato il nostro universo in diverse fasi
della sua evoluzione e attraverso queste
istantanee possiamo ricostruire la sua
storia possiamo leggere il suo tempo
questo è senza dubbio l'aspetto più
affascinante del nostro lavoro
concettualmente è abbastanza semplice
l'avete sentito non c'è niente di
misterioso
tecnicamente un pochino più complesso
perché la luce che arriva da molto
lontano e anche molto debole e quindi
molto difficile da misurare
è una continua sfida tecnologica che ci
spinge ci ha spinto attraverso i secoli
a costruire telescopi sempre più potenti
e sofisticati
il telescopio spaziale hubble è
l'esempio per eccellenza telescopi
sempre più grandi in grado di
raccogliere la poca luce che riceviamo
da sorgenti sempre più distanti
telescopi che ci permettono di vedere
anche quella parte della radiazione a
cui il nostro occhio non è sensibile
telescopi che funzionano proprio come
delle macchine del tempo perché se è
vero che non ci consentono di viaggiare
nel passato ci permettono però di
vederlo il passato e allora proviamo
adesso insieme a vedere il passato del
nostro universo
partiamo ad esempio dalle galassie le
galassie sono insieme di stelle
centinaia di miliardi di stelle gas e
polvere materia oscura il tutto tenuto
insieme dalla gravità
potete immaginare un po come i mattoni
che costituiscono il nostro universo
questa è la bellissima galassia di
andromeda la nostra vicina di casa di
cui ho parlato prima e il corpo celeste
più distante che riusciamo a vedere ad
occhio nudo anche se naturalmente non
con questo livello di dettaglio
noi supponiamo che andromeda sia molto
simile alla nostra galassia la via
lattea che invece non possiamo
fotografare perché ci viviamo dentro ne
possiamo mandare un telescopio là fuori
perché l'avrete capito le distanze sono
enormi e i nostri telescopi non
viaggiano certo alla velocità della luce
ma sono molto molto più lenti quindi
mettiamoci l'animo in pace la nostra
galassia possiamo osservarla solo da
dentro però possiamo osservare le altre
galassie e qui ora sorge un problema
noi vogliamo capire come le galassie
cambiano nel tempo ma i tempi scala su
cui questi cambiamenti avvengono sono
dell'ordine di milioni miliardi di anni
e noi non abbiamo questo tempo a
disposizione
che si fa
immaginate di essere un extraterrestre
che è in visita sulla terra e ha una
sola ora a disposizione per comprendere
il genere umano
voi che fareste
io mi metterei a scattare delle
fotografie a individui di diverso tipo
bambini neonati ragazzi adulti anziani
giovani donne col pancione così via
e poi una volta tornata a casa
comincerei ad analizzare queste
fotografie per cercare relazioni tra i
vari individui e così ricostruire il
percorso della vita umana
ecco con le galassie facciamo una cosa
molto simile ne registriamo le immagini
migliaia milioni in diverse regioni
dell'universo in diverse epoche in
diverse fasi della loro evoluzione è
l'insieme di tutte queste informazioni
pezzo dopo pezzo perché la scienza
funziona così si costruisce lentamente
un pezzo per volta
insomma l'insieme di tutte queste
immagini ci racconta come le galassie
sono evolute questa è una collezione di
immagini di galassie simili alla nostra
via lattea sulla sinistra vedete
galassie vicine a noi vicine sempre
rispetto agli standard del cosmo chiare
ma chiaramente e verso destra galassie
via via più distanti quindi più antiche
le ultime risalgono a 11 miliardi di
anni fa ovvero la loro luce ha viaggiato
per 11 miliardi di anni prima di essere
raccolta dai nostri telescopi oggi
l'universo a 13,8
anni appare immediatamente chiaro che le
galassie non sono sempre state uguali
oggi le galassie come la nostra hanno
delle forme a spirale molto belle come
andromeda che ho mostrato prima nel
passato avevano forme più irregolari
erano più piccole e più blu
e da queste caratteristiche noi capiamo
la fisica che regola questi sistemi ad
esempio il fatto che fossero più blu ci
sta dicendo che nel passato i processi
di formazione stellare al loro interno
erano più intensi rispetto ad oggi
10 11 miliardi di anni fa l'universo
formava mediamente dieci volte più nuove
stelle rispetto a quanto non faccia oggi
un po come un ragazzo che è più energico
di una persona matura
ecco nello stesso modo l'universo
attraversato nella sua giovinezza una
fase di massima attività e oggi che
diciamo più maturo è un luogo più
tranquillo
questa è una delle tante evidenze che ci
mostra come il nostro universo sia in
continua evoluzione
guardiamo ancora più indietro
guardate questa la galassia più distante
che oggi conosciamo è stata individuata
da un team dell'università di yale
per darvi un'idea di quanto sia debole
il suo segnale
avete presente se di notte guardate il
cielo ad occhio nudo le stelline più
deboli e più fioche che riuscite a
vedere
ecco la luce di questa galassia è 10
miliardi di volte più debole di quelle
stelle misurarla è stato un po come
riuscire a vedere una lucciola sulla
luna sembra impossibile eppure eccola
qua potrebbe non sembra particolarmente
interessante sembra solo una macchiolina
rossa ma la sua immagine proviene da un
epoca in cui l'universo aveva solo 400
milioni di anni che poi 400 milioni se
può sembrare un numero grande ma è molto
piccolo rispetto a 14 miliardi di anni
che l'età del nostro universo oggi
stiamo veramente guardando vicino alla
sua origine con telescopi sempre più
potenti ci spingiamo a guardare sempre
più lontano è sempre più indietro nel
tempo il prossimo obiettivo
quello di riuscire ad osservare le prime
stelle le prime galassie che si sono
formate circa 200 milioni di anni dopo
il big bang
ma fin dove quanto indietro possiamo
spingere il nostro sguardo
la risposta a questa domanda e 380.000
anni dopo il big bang
e non si tratta di un limite strumentale
dovuta al fatto che non siamo capaci di
costruire telescopi migliori ma di un
limite fisico invalicabile e che
attenzione non vuol dire che non
sappiamo cosa sia successo prima lo
abbiamo capito da altre evidenze siamo
in grado di spiegare l'evoluzione del
nostro universo a partire da una
frazione infinitesima di secondo dopo il
big bang
non sappiamo spiegare esattamente
l'istante iniziale perché le leggi della
fisica che conosciamo perdono di
validità nelle condizioni di estrema
temperatura ed estrema densità che hanno
caratterizzato l'origine del nostro
universo
ma insomma parte l'istante iniziale
abbiamo capito cos'è nei primi 380.000
anni della sua vita
lo abbiamo capito ma non possiamo
vederlo
e non possiamo vederlo perché fino a
quel momento la luce non si propagava la
luce c'era ma era come intrappolata in
una sorta di nebbia dovete immaginare
l'universo dell'epoca come una scatola
di palline che continuamente rimbalzano
l'una sull'altra e le palline di questo
enorme flipper se così vogliamo vederlo
che era il nostro universo erano i
fotoni che sono le particelle che
trasportano il segnale luminoso e i
costituenti dell'atomo quindi nuclei ed
elettroni sapete che la materia è fatta
di atomi e gli atomi sono fatti da un
nucleo e da elettroni che gli girano
intorno
all'epoca l'universo era talmente caldo
che tutto il suo calore la sua energia
non permettevano alle elettroni agli
elettroni di girare intorno ai nuclei e
gli elettroni se ne stavano sparpagliati
in questo miscuglio di radiazione
materia che era l'universo primordiale
espandendosi l'universo è andato via via
raffreddandosi e solo quando la sua
temperatura è scesa sotto i 3000 gradi
circa cosa che appunto è successo a
380.000 anni dopo il big bang
solo a quel punto gli elettori
e hanno smesso di andarsene in giro a
rimbalzare contro i fotoni contro la
luce e si sono legati ai nuclei e la
nebbia si è diradata
da quel momento in poi la luce ha
cominciato a viaggiare praticamente
indisturbata e a coprire le lunghe
distanze che separano quell'epoca da noi
e ci ha portato un'immagine di quel
momento questa è l'immagine più antica
che possiamo avere del nostro universo
come appariva a 380.000 anni dopo il big
bang quando la nebbia si è diradata
l'ovale che vedete rappresenta una mappa
di tutto il cielo è questa mappa
racchiude una quantità immensa di
informazioni ci racconta ad esempio come
l'universo dell'epoca fosse molto
diverso da quello attuale non c'erano
stelle galassie e gli enormi vuoti che
separano una galassia dall'altra ma
c'era solo gas è tutto praticamente alla
stessa temperatura l'universo era
estremamente omogeneo in questa estrema
uniformità però si riconoscono delle
regioni solo leggerissimamente più dense
più calde della media le macchioline
rosse che vedete sulla mappa e quando
dico leggerissimamente intendo per una
parte su 100.000 quindi ancora una volta
capite bene
una sfida tecnologica non da poco
riuscire ad ottenere questa misura ci
sono voluti decenni
insomma in queste regioni solo
leggerissimamente più dense della media
col passare del tempo per effetto della
gravità è andato accumulandosi sempre
più materia che poi ha dato origine alle
stelle alle galassie che osserviamo noi
oggi con i nostri telescopi continuando
ad andare indietro nel tempo esaurito il
tempo del mio intervento e dobbiamo
salutarci
in questi pochi minuti vi ho raccontato
come la luce non propagandosi
istantaneamente ci permette di vedere il
passato del nostro universo
ho finora ho messo un piccolo
particolare su cui non posso del tutto
sorvolare e cioè che in realtà la luce
ci svela solo una piccola parte solo un
4 per cento del contenuto totale del
nostro universo
tutto il resto non emette e non assorbe
luce ma nonostante ciò la luce ci
permette di ricostruire la storia del
nostro universo
di scorrere tutto il suo tempo
attraverso una serie di istantanee fino
ad un'epoca molto vicina al suo inizio e
da queste istantanee abbiamo imparato
come l'universo è cambiato nei suoi 14
miliardi di anni di vita
abbiamo imparato a conoscere il suo
presente e possiamo fare delle
supposizioni su quale potrebbe essere il
suo futuro
certo rimangono ancora molte questioni
aperte
molti aspetti che non comprendiamo del
tutto oppure ahimè non comprendiamo per
niente e quindi non ci resta che
continuare a osservare il cielo
affrontando ogni giorno nuove sfide alla
ricerca di nuove risposte